Hop out of bed for some eggs Bunny Side up
and then wage backyard garden warfare with
the Pollinator Beebomb.
Because it’s episode 55 of LÜT.
Emerge from the shadows and learn to harness
them with the Shadow Puppets Mug, and once
you’ve mastered hand manipulation take a
crack at a full-body challenge on an inflatable
obstacle course from N-Flatables.
You can rent them for parties, festivals or
just because they’re awesome and they have
everything from Hidden Temple Courses to Robo-Rampage.
After you’ve had a whale of a time use these
Whale Knives to prepare dinner, but if you
find a spider in the salad bust out this Spider
Catching Gun to keep it from scrabbling away.
Speaking of scrabble, why not add some alphabetic
flair to your living room with the Scrabble
Light Set which you can use to spell whatever
you want.
Mark wherever you’ve been on Earth with
the Scratch Map and watch as your travels
change the world, or at least the color of
the world map.
If you get thirsty on your journeys grab a
Zing Water Bottle which features a built-in
fruit press so you can add some fruity zest
to whatever you’re drinking.
But no matter what you do, Donut Forget Sticky
Notes.
Do not be afraid to learn some Japanese with
the Jinmenken Haunted School Escape Board
Game.
The Jinmenken is a Japanese monster dog with
a human face, and you need your character
to collect various items around the school
before he catches you.
If you end up in the school cafeteria, take
a break from running for your life and enjoy
a personalized chocolate pizza made from Belgian
chocolate.
Select from one of six different flavors and
personalize the message plaque in the middle,
making it a great item to bring to somebody’s
birthday.
And since it’s their birthday, you might
as well give them the never ending birthday
card which once opened plays a birthday jingle
continuously for at least 3 hours -- even
if it’s ripped up, submerged under water,
or set on fire.
After all that annoying music, the adults
might wanna sink into a Gin and Titonic and
then trick their brains into perceiving fluid
motion with the busy body optical illusion
toy.
Based on a zoetrope, the Busy Body lets you
pose a number of mannequins placed around
a mirror and then create your own real life
animated GIF by giving it a spin.
When they’ve run so much they’ve worn
out their shoes, grab a pair of these sneaker
soaps which come in styles from Adidas Superstar
soaps to Air Jordans.
Then when you get sick of the air, head to
the ocean with deep sea sand art, an interactive
piece of art that has undersea mountains that
form before your very eyes.
Open your eyes underwater after attaching
the GoFish cam and get high quality footage
of anything caught on your fishing line.
It has night vision and can connect to your
phone so you can see what’s down there,
but if you don’t check the footage, then
the fish both is and isn’t caught, just
like this Schrodinger Cat Mug.
But to be sure your dinner does exist, sign
up for the Carnivore Club which sends you
a box of artisanal meat every month, like
South African dried meats or Canadian maple
jerky.
Eat your meat inside the Gazebox, a re-sealable
cover that can act as both a gazebo, and a
carport.
Now that you have a garage, it’s time to
buy a home -- a spaceship home.
Made by Noem, the spaceship home is built
from three modules, is eco-friendly, and is
largely automated, so if you ever wanted to
live in a spaceship, this is probably your
best chance.
Though it is missing something ah yes an Inflatable
Bath Tub.
Just make sure you place it far away from
your Frankenstein Light Switch.
Because if I let you get electrocuted, people
are going to say I’m Cold Hearted Pluto.
And as always - thanks for watching!